Let's go back to the phone lines getting towards
the
end of what has been a very, very busy week,
uh, in politics and at the David Pakman show,
(617) 830-4750. Let's go to our caller from
the two six, seven area code color from two,
six, seven. Uh, what's your name? Where are
you calling from?
Is this a may?
Yes, it is.
Hello. Hey, David Dolan. Uh, I just wanted
to ask you about, uh, their opinion on globalism
and your opinion on going. I heard you talk
about both, but not in relation to each other.
I have this area that if we went into a like
semi globalists are fully global, is controlled
like world that uh, if we didn't have any
populous like America that was like fully
armed, I think the statistics were that there's
300 million registered firearms in America
and that there's, you know, about 300 million
people. That would mean that each American
could take arms against, let's say the American
populace or not the American populace, the
American military, let's say they had a deployment,
they can only put out about 200,000 people.
So they stand no chance. Again, the American
populace. So I look at it like the American
populace is kind of the, uh, big brother of
the world's populace to keep the government
in check. Would you be still in favor of a
globalist agenda if we didn't have firearms
in one massive population of citizens?
Wow. There is so much there that has to be
dis-aggregated before. I mean, the question
as asked is a tangle of conjecture, a conspiratorial
thinking and misunderstanding. So let's see
if we can, to just untangle a few things.
When you talk about globalism, are you talking
about a OneWorld government sort of, uh, uh,
setup as there are some on the internet who
talk about, are you talking about globalism
via coalitions of countries? Are you talking
about coalition globalism merely in recognizing
that on some issues, like for example, global
warming, these issues go beyond the borders
of a country. So we've got to work together.
Like what are you talking about when you say
globalism?
So I would believe that it would start as
a coalition as no one would allow for a one
world government. I would think that if there
was no armed populace, that it would be a
coalition that, you know, flight into a OneWorld
controlled government. You know, that would
be kind of like a behind the scenes, a deep
state action that we wouldn't have the sand
as a, as a world populace.
Now, why have not? Why, why hasn't that been
attempted now? And the reason I asked that
is in the sense, I mean there are lots of
firearms floating around in the U S but a
lot of the coalitions that currently exist
to which the U S is party are countries with
very little gun ownership, for example, where
if they all wanted to work together, they
could very quickly, as you're sort of suggesting
dominate the local population. Like why, why
have we not seen an effort to do by any of
these, um, uh, international coalitions
simply because they're afraid of the American
government? Because, uh, the populace wouldn't
allow them to do anti-democratic or like anti
libertarian or anti Liberty things,
but they're allies with the American government,
their income, their income with the American
government. The American government is part
of those coalitions. You're saying that were
it not for the American government, the [inaudible]
for example, or NATO countries or whoever
would have already tried to establish one
world rule in on on this planet. Is that what
you're arguing? But the U S keeps them from
doing that.
I'm saying that they would have if they weren't
afraid of the American populace revolting
against their anti Liberty and anti-democratic
policies overseas.
Yeah. Well, the problem with these theories
is that it's impossible to prove why something
didn't happen. And unfortunately that's the
sort of point in the discussion we've gotten
to a Dillon. It's interesting, I think a,
there's no evidence whatsoever for what you're
saying, but I appreciate you presenting it
to me.
All right. Thank you, ma'am.
Are we good? All right. Thanks very much.
Take care.